the days of the Andals were numbered one
by one their so-called Kings were
bending the knee or facing the wrath of
Aegon Targaryen Aegon of old Valyria
Aegon who was blood of the dragon after
defeating the iron men at Harrenhal and
slaying the last of the storm kings
Aegon and his sisters Ramos and Visenya
set their sights on other prizes the
gold mines of the rock and the fertile
lands of the reach King Loren Lannister
of the rock and King Mern gardener of
the reach foolishly thought their
combined armies could beat back the
Targaryen host they rode forth together
their proud banners flapping in the wind
and faced off against Aegon in a vast
golden field of wheat the two kings
commanded a massive force of nearly
60,000 and it appeared the day was
theirs until Aegon unleashed all three
of his dragons for the first and only
time each beast was named after the
Valyrian gods of Aegon's forefathers
Visenya rode vhagar 'the could melt
armor Rhaenys rode meraxes whose jaws
were big enough to swallow a horse hole
greatest of all was balerion the black
dread with fire dark as night and wings
so huge whole towns were covered in
shadow when he flew overhead this
magnificent creature
was written by Aegon himself four
thousand men were bathed in glorious
dragon flame that day on what came to be
known as the field of fire King Mern was
among the dead and house gardener died
with him
his stewards the turell's surrendered
his ancestral stronghold of Highgarden
to Aegon and were appointed Lords
paramount of the reach and wardens of
the south when loren lannister witnessed
man's fate he wisely bent the knee Aegon
spared Lauren's life and the Lannisters
were made Lords paramount of the
westerland's and wardens of the West
after his triumph from the field of fire
Aegon's conquest was assured in a short
time the so-called Seven Kingdoms were
melted down in the heat of the Dragons
flame and transformed into a single
realm Aegon would forever be known as
Aegon the conquerer